while most companies understand the
benefits of automation and have even
adopted some automation capabilities
into their operations it can be
challenging to achieve the full value of
an automation solution especially when
faced with potential challenges like
prioritizing or scaling automation
projects across the enterprise
businesses need an automation solution
that will identify what processes and
projects will be best served by
automation for the greatest roi
with flexible deployment options that
allow them to get started quickly and
easily
and finally they need an intelligent
automation strategy that can be
incorporated into existing systems and
scaled easily
enter ibm cloudpack for business
automation
with a modular set of integrated
software cloud pack for business
automation is built for any cloud and
offers a broad set of ai-powered
automation capabilities
including process mining
rpa content
capture
decisions and workflow
you can integrate it into your existing
environments wherever you are today
and scale easily while bringing security
and transparency to your operations
as an ai-powered automation solution you
can use ibm cloudpack for business
automation to
augment your workforce with ai and
digital employees freeing your human
employees to focus on higher value work
automate your core operations to improve
efficiency and productivity
create business applications easily with
no and low code tools to give business
leaders the agility to deliver better
customer experiences
you can apply actionable insights using
deep learning to obtain ai-powered
recommendations for shared data
and apply intelligence to processes and
tasks for more agile operations and
continuous improvement
and finally measure impact with built-in
analytics to track your business
performance
ibm cloud pack for business automation
is already helping to transform
operations and speed innovation for a
variety of businesses
for example
by achieving straight through processing
for 97 of new margin and option requests
td ameritrade maintained top-notch
customer service during skyrocketing
demand
by enabling financing applicants to
submit documentation for mobile devices
turxcell reduced approvals from days to
minutes
with ibm cloudback for business
automation you can make every experience
and process more intelligent
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe